[Music]
i'm lauren zima here at the race to
erase ms red carpet at the fabulous
Beverly Hilton and Paris Hilton herself
just closed out the carpet you guys she
was a princess with her prints on her
arm and we found out just how serious
their love connection is I got to ask
you about something I saw in that very
significant left hand is there a ring on
that left hand what's the deal this is
actually a gift from my friend Rosalina
okay this is not an engagement ring yeah
what is not yet me you'll find out
you seem very in love you can't keep
your hands off each other
absolutely fool me for sure what is it
about each other that means you both
know soul mate
you wake up with a smile and you fall
asleep with a smile being best friends
and finally finding someone that I love
and trust and know that I want to spend
the rest of my life with the best
feeling in the world I saw your mom over
there you know your whole family's here
supporting tonight what does mom think
of this guy my mom loves him she's
definitely approves it's just so happy
she already says he's part of the family
so you've known Nancy your whole life
how meaningful is it to be here I mean
you get very emotional thinking about
your grandmother and everything that you
was losing my grandmother 2ms was so
painful and I love that Nancy really
puts so much work and effort into this
event every year and they're finding
cures and they're really making a huge
difference so I always want to be here
and support her every single year okay
so when's the wedding
[Music]